rise and shine it's an spresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right grab your cup of coffee and
sip on today's message push the limits
over to you Elon Musk also if you want
to know what Elon and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
description below there are times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that you do it in
spite of the fear how do you come with
this ID actually sometime they're
pushing the human limit you are always
pushing the human limit why I think
about what's what technology solution is
necessary in order to achieve the
particular goal and then try to make as
much progress in that direction as
possible being a multi-planet species
being out there among the stars is
important for the long-term survival of
humanity and that's one reason kind of
like life insurance for life
collectively life as we know it but then
the part that I find personally most
motivating is that it creates a sense of
adventure and it makes people excited
about the future now if you consider two
futures one where we are forever
confined to earth until eventually
something terrible happens or another
future where we are out there on many
planets maybe even going beyond the
solar system I think that second version
is incredibly exciting and inspiring and
they need to be reasons to get up in the
morning you know life can't just be
about solving problems otherwise what's
the point
it's got to be things that people find
inspiring and make life worth living
most people slack off in life
because their reason for getting up in
the morning isn't strong enough because
there why isn't strong enough because
hitting the snooze button five times and
sleeping in is more important for you
than your why your why isn't important
enough and until you fix that equation
until that changes nothing in your life
your quality of life the status of your
business will change now having a strong
why find your why I can often feel like
mushy soft not practical not
implementable advice but guys listen if
this is you if you legit have a hard
time getting up every morning and you're
slamming that snooze button then this is
the most practical thing that you need
to do in your life if you are frustrated
with the quality of your life and this
is the thing that needs to change
and I'm gonna give you three ways to do
it number one is your purpose comes from
your pain understand that your deepest
darkest most painful moments is the path
forward we like to avoid them we like to
forget about them we like to try to move
past those past issues and problems and
we want to think about positivity and
optimism in the better world which is
amazing
but the path to create that is through
the mess is through the chaos is through
all the pain that you have been through
I think humans are naturally wired to
help we want to help we want to serve
like 99% of humans want to serve even
more 99.999% of humans want to serve and
the best way that you can serve is to
help people who are currently going
through the issues that you have been
through or going through right now
yourself so start by thinking about the
most painful moments that you've had to
deal with in your life maybe that was
with your parents maybe your
grandparents maybe your teachers your
classmates your neighbors whatever the
most painful moments were in your life
and how did you get through it the
reason why I do what I do is not because
entrepreneurs are gonna solve every
world problem which I think we will it's
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur to get started myself I
felt so little respect for myself that I
felt like I don't want any human being
to have to feel how I'm feeling right
now that's why I do what I do and when
you can figure that out ask yourself the
feelings that you found
the darkest dark the lowest low you
never want people to feel this ever that
is your purpose that is your mission
what do you want people to never have to
feel or suffer that you've been through
that's how you find your why
step number two is take money off the
table listen money is really important
money is important for everybody even if
you're a charity money is super super
super duper important it's just not
number one and we do stupid things for
money when you are pressed for money
when you are tight for money you do
stupid things that are against the
long-term interests of your business
your thinking so short-term that it
prevents you from having the success and
building the business and brand that you
want to do honestly if you are in a
massive cash crunch right now if you are
if you are just I can't pay my bills
next week if that's how you're focused
get a job get a job to alleviate the
immediate financial burden and hopefully
get a job or you're gonna learn
something about the industry you're
gonna get into so that you can focus on
making the right decisions for your
business so take money off the table for
a few moments and start to think if
money was not the restriction then what
would I be doing
you wouldn't shovel forever and you
wouldn't buy your mom a thousand homes
like at some point you're gonna come
down to I want purpose and meaning in my
life so when you figured out your
purpose from your pain great now what
are you gonna do about it
assume money is not the issue take it
off the table what actions are you going
to be doing to further that mission and
step number three is obsess the process
so you have to love the work that you're
doing if you look at anybody who's has
success the people who you look up to
and respect they love the work they're
on a mission they have purpose it comes
from their pain they're not doing it for
the money money is number two or three
but it's not number one they've done
that but they like the work they like
the day-to-day they like the grind they
like the activities that they're doing
every single day I'm reading this book
about Martin Luther King and he had this
great quote just after he won the Nobel
Peace Prize it's on top of this
marvelous mountain he just won this big
award but the valley calls to me he
wants to get back it's not about the
award it's not about the recognition
it's not about the fame and the glory
and the money it's about the work it's
about the valley it's about the process
the doing so take my purpose I love
helping
burners then look at the process I love
making videos this is great this is why
I have the subscribers that I have
what's why I can do 6000 videos because
I love the process I don't love podcasts
I don't love consuming content audio I
used to have a radio show
I dropped it because he didn't love the
process because I couldn't see the
person that I'm communicating with I
want to see the person I'm a visual
learner and so if my success depended on
me only having a radio show or only
having a podcast I would lose I would do
it if that was the only path because
that helps me get to my purpose if that
was the only path but it's not so what I
encourage you to do is make a list of
all the different ways that you have
helped people with this purpose you've
been through this pain you know your
purpose you've helped people in a lot of
different ways what are the ways that
you actually enjoyed not the result not
the result of them being happy and
you've helped them but the process do
you like meeting with people one on one
do you like writing articles you like
making videos do you like investing into
people's companies do you like being a
mentor and going for coffee with people
like what's the process the process that
you enjoy when you figure that out all
three of those things when you
understand that your purpose comes to
your pain you know what your purpose is
after examining the pain when you
understand that it's not about making
money money is important but it's not
number one and then when you enjoy the
day-to-day you enjoy the process you're
doing work that feels you up every
single day you just hit a home run
you've won for life so the goal here is
to bring more energy to your life the
goal here is to be doing work that
excites you so much that you don't want
to snooze five times that your reason to
get up is greater than your reason to
stay in bed and that feels like a really
low bar it feels like a really low bar
that's sleeping in and hitting the
snooze button is more important than
your life's work and so I hope these
three steps helped you and I'm super
pumped to see what you're gonna create
from them now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day I want to know what
is your strong why and if you don't know
it yet what are some of the pieces of it
what are some of the elements that you
think might be close to it and maybe we
can figure it out together with the help
of
leave nation leave your thoughts down
the comments below
my message to people whether it's on
stage or in the podcast or anything is
that you know we are more than what
we're demonstrating that we've been sold
this lie that people are taught through
school like when I do these demos and I
understand stage memorize hundred names
and words and numbers forwards and
backwards and it appears effortlessly I
always tell people I don't do this
impress you I do to express to you
what's really possible because the truth
is everyone can do this too and so much
more apply towards creativity and focus
and flow and problem-solving and
thinking and and really overcoming the
biggest challenges of their life and
maybe even the world the challenges we
were taught a lot we were taught a lie
that somehow our intelligence our
potential are learning or memories
somehow is fixed or creativity is fixed
or thinking is fixed like our shoe size
and what we've discovered you know as
you know more vehement about brain
science in the past two decades we
discovered more than the previous 2,000
years and what we know is that we're
grossly underestimated its capacity our
own capacity to be able to grow to be
able to contribute to improve our
intelligence and our influence and our
impact and I'm really I want to kind of
pull the veil behind and just say hey
this is about transcending you know this
is about ending the trance ending the
trance that you're that we're not good
enough you know that we're not smart
enough that we you're not this genius
and and telling the truth and the truth
is people can we're faster and we're
smarter than we think and not just to be
able to wrote and memorize things but be
able to really solve significant
challenges and maybe that these
challenges that we're going through or
the lessons that we need to to learn the
most and then some people who learn
those lessons feel compelled to be able
to share that voice with other people so
it's not just one candle you know we
just can set things ablaze raise your
standard Apple at the core is core value
is that we believe that people with
passion can change the world not one
drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance a man if you want to learn
how to stretch your limits I think
you're really gonna enjoy the one rule
video we did on it it's right next to me
go check it out
continue to believe and I'll see you
there so limited limits don't limit
yourself conquer the limitations
limitless